après le premier tour la situation est
claire le régime qui en disant
d'incapacité n'a pas réussi à donner à
la jeunesse du pays la moindre confiance
dans l'avenir qui lui prépare et qui est
responsable de la crise de mai sort
renforcé des urnes cela était prévisible
mais cela a des conséquences
la première conséquence n'est pas que de
détails elle concerne l'âge du droit de
vote et le mode de scrutin
les forces dont la protestation a
déclenché la crise de mai seront
absentes du parlement ce n'est pas une
bonne manière de commencer le dialogue
un système politique et
constitutionnelle ne peut fonctionner
sans crise que lorsque à tout le moins
il donne la parole à tous les
interlocuteurs
ceux qui contestent la société actuelle
et notamment la jeunesse
le feront d'autant plus fortement qu ils
ne peuvent pas s'y exprimer par les
voies légales aucun système politique ne
saurait résister durablement un tel
décalage
la seconde conséquence concerne le
gaullisme
renforcée disposant d'une majorité
inconditionnels plus sûr que jamais
durci par l'ouverture à droite que
représente la libération de salon et de
la chaux roi il aura moins que jamais la
volonté de créer les relations
politiques démocratiques qui sont
tellement nécessaire à notre pays et qui
suppose le respect de l'opposition est
en tout cas le respect de sa totale
liberté d'expression sur ce point
l'absence de toute satisfaction donner
aux revendications légitimes des
journalistes de l'eau et rtf est un très
mauvais signe
pour limiter tant que faire se peut la
toute puissance du pouvoir gaulliste
aujourd'hui il n'est plus qu'une arme
c'est qu'aucune voie de gauche ne manque
au candidat unique de la gauche restait
en lice dans de très nombreuses
circonscriptions
à tous ceux électeurs et électrices
socialiste convaincu qui hésiteraient
devant un tel vote à cause des positions
récemment prises par la fédération à
gauche et le parti communiste français
le parti socialiste unifié répète
inlassablement qu'on ne saurait
poursuivre tous les objectifs politiques
à la fois l'objectif politique
prioritaire aujourd'hui c'est la
limitation des pouvoirs du gaullisme
c'est un problème de clarté politique
mais le même souci de la clarté
politique nous conduites a précisé que
les centristes ne peuvent pas être nos
alliés bien au contraire ils défendent
avec acharnement un système économique
et social périmés dans ces conditions en
traçant triste et un gaulliste le seul
choix possible
c'est l'abstention
la troisième conséquence de ce scrutin
la plus grave concerne notre avenir
il est aujourd'hui à craindre en effet
que cet avenir ne puisse se préparer au
parlement où ne sont représentés que des
forces du passé
nous avons appris au mois de mai que les
étudiants les enseignants les ouvriers
les techniciens l'écart et dans de
nombreuses régions les paysans qui
protestaient contre les conditions de
leur vie quotidienne exigeait en fait
des solutions socialiste
il faut donc pour préparer notre avenir
commun
précise et inlassablement le contenu
détaillé de ces solutions socialiste et
tout en même temps construire la grande
force socialiste ouverte et démocratique
capable de succès d'héroïsme
cette force socialiste doit se
construire sans esprit de sectes le ps
ua tenue déjà d'innombrables réunions ou
forums ouverts à tous sans considération
de l'organisation qu'elle chacun
appartient pour discuter en détail des
formes de la société a créé gestion des
entreprises structures de la coopération
agricole contenu d'une culture nouvelle
ouverte à tous
organisation d'université exercice et
fonctionnement des professions libérales
dimension internationale et notamment
européennes de la politique socialiste à
entreprendre tout ceci doit être un
rassemblement discuter il faut que ces
réunions continue le ps eut pour sa part
s'ils déclarent tout à fait résolus
la force socialiste capable de succéder
au gaullisme doit d'autre part être tout
aussi capable de faire triompher ses
points de vue et ses espérances en
utilisant pleinement tous les moyens que
lui offre l'action légale et
parlementaires mais aussi en sachant
donner leurs traductions politiques
concrètes aux mouvements populaires
partout où ils se produisent et chaque
fois qu'ils se produisent dans
l'ensemble du pays
avec tous ceux qui sont d'accord sur de
telles bases et sans aucune autre
exclusive le parti socialiste unifié se
déclarent aujourd'hui prêt à constituer
le grand courant socialiste qui est
nécessaire à notre comme une victoire